truly it's it's a gift
it really is a gift ahead of what would
have been the late kobe bryant's 43rd
birthday vanessa bryan and daughters
natalia bianca and capri visited
disneyland a place has been a favorite
of the bryant family before and after
the passing of kobe and his daughter
gianna i shake my shoe
i [ __ ] my shoes over the weekend vanessa
who refers to the amusement park as
their quote happy place and her oldest
natalia shared a glimpse into their
fun-filled disney day on instagram
[Music]
vanessa shared this sweet clip of her
and four-year-old bianca enjoying the
guardians of the galaxy ride
the mom celebrated her daughter by
captioning the video quote bibi is such
a trooper and we got our favorite song
on this ride the kid does not stop like
we call it a little mini tornado 18 year
old college freshman natalia bryant
showed off her school spirit and her
love for disneyland with this pic that
shows her rocking university of southern
california themed mickey mouse ears her
mom reposted the snapshot and simply
captioned it quote fight on with a heart
and kissy face emoji vanessa also shared
this photo which shows off her bracelets
dedicated to each one of her daughters
and kobe you can see kobe's name right
next to giannis who along with her dad
at the age of 13 unfortunately lost her
life in that tragic january 26
helicopter crash vanessa captioned the
photo quote always with me with the
heart emoji gigi's a basketball player
yeah she is the she's in it yeah does
she have that inner focus like her daddy
yeah she's uh she's a stone cold killer
on what would have been kobe's 43rd
birthday natalia paid tribute to her dad
on instagram writing quote happy
birthday daddy with a heart emoji and
vanessa honored her late husband writing
quote i love you forever eternal love in
spanish with a broken heart emoji and
the number 43.
[Music]
you